so in the script I wrote this in a
bullet point as cold-open because I
couldn't think of anything in specific
and I mean that's what I do when I
script I just if I hit a point where I'm
not quite sure what to do I try to just
write a sentence or two outside of the
voice of the script literally describing
what needs to happen to join where the
script is at to the point that's
following it it's a very utilitarian
method but it helps me get around
writer's block and minimize problems
where different ideas will make unstated
logical leaps in between and then the
longer I stared at it the more absurd it
became because you know it's the cold
open to the art of editing and the
Snowman and it just sat there taunting
me practically begging for a joke or
some setup for a pun that would make
Joel Schumacher cringe in his seat and
now after building it up really hyping
the hell out of it just like the Snowman
I'm now going to drop this entire bit
and never reference it again the snowman
is a 2017 film directed by Tomas
Alfredson based on the Scandinavian noir
novel of the same name written by Jo
Nesbo the film stars michael fassbender
as down-on-his-luck alcoholic detective
harry hole as he unravels the identity
of a serial killer who abducts and
dismembers women leaving behind a
snowman as a calling card the film has
gained substantial notoriety for being a
complete forking mess even the director
agrees in an interview with the
Norwegian national broadcaster the NRK
Alfredsson suggested that due to the
rushed shooting schedule of 30 days and
limited access to locations as much as
10 to 15 percent of the script hadn't
actually been filmed leaving huge gaps
in the story that needed to be either
bridged or restructured in editing I
would suggest that things are even more
dire than that makes it sound failing to
shoot 15 percent of the film is going to
leave literal plot holes so large that
the only solution is to excise the plot
lines entirely leaving even more of the
script on the cutting room floor
the
result he's delirious she said she was
going to visit a friend and she never
came back why did you come to me I've
been suspended I'm going to admit that
I'm excited and nervous because this one
is such a mess that I'm still not sure I
entirely have a handle on the film every
time I watch it something new jumps out
there's always another detail that goes
nowhere another plot thread that
disappears another scene that connects
two events that were never shown but
we're going to try as we get into this I
want to restate the same thing that I
did with Suicide Squad when people say a
movie has bad editing they're going to
be talking mainly about two different
kinds of editing shot-to-shot and scene
to scene or momentary editing and
structural editing momentary editing is
the nitty gritty editing what kinds of
cuts are used where they placed how far
apart are they spaced how well is
continuity preserved does a match edit
actually work does intercut dialogue
feel right can we follow the action
properly so on and so forth
structural editing is the bigger picture
what order are scenes in how is the
movie as a whole pasted when our
flashbacks inserted our locations and
geography properly established are
foreshadowing and callbacks properly
implemented and all of that the Snowman
like Suicide Squad is littered with both
problems extending from this one of the
things that I want to address is how
we're going about the discussion here
we're talking about the art of editing
but not exclusively in a lot of ways
editing is simply the vector that we're
using to discuss other elements of the
filmmaking or more specifically we're
addressing other elements of the
filmmaking because of how they end up
manifesting in the Edit for example
early in the film in a scene where Harry
shows up at work and his superior
officer gunner Hagen gives him a whole
clean up your act I can't keep covering
for you speech in the cafeteria stripped
to an absolute bare-bones factual
description the scene is fine the
dialogue is fine
the acting is fine the pace of the cuts
the flow from close up to insert to
medium the use of split edits it's all
fine but for some reason almost every
single shot in the scene is blocked with
a lateral slide hairy's shots moving
from right to left
Gunnar's moving from left to right in
isolation these are also fine but
consideration wasn't taken for how these
shots would then cut together and the
Edit doesn't consider the change in
motion vector from one shot to the other
resulting in a scene that feels like
it's bouncing back and forth like a ping
pong ball and then spice it up with this
jarring edit the conventional editing
style which is generally used throughout
the film is to preserve lines of motion
from one shot to the next while using
neutral moments as a visual buffer to
give the audience a moment to reset this
is conventional continuity editing which
is the continuity of action subject and
motion with slight discontinuity used to
build tension in what is meant to be an
energetic suspenseful scene going back
to the cafeteria example there's no
motivation for this movement it's two
characters having a low-key conversation
in hushed tones maybe using this motion
on a couple key bits of dialogue could
add some interest to the scene or if
Harry's shot had some slight motion
while Gunnar's was more static it would
be conveying an emotional state but
simply having the motion mirrored across
every single shot for an entire minute
of dialogue it's just dizzying for no
purpose again while these issues are
going to intersect several different
elements of filmmaking from the
camerawork to the script filmmaking is
symbiotic to the degree that flaws or
failures in one area will impact the
ability for others to do their jobs so
while we will be talking about a whole
host of issues we will be approaching
those issues from the direction of the
Edit before we go further we should
probably address the name issue and
people who are familiar with the source
material already know
going with this I've already said the
main character's name is Harry Hole and
that's not entirely accurate but it is
accurate to this film in Norwegian the
character's name would be pronounced
closer to Hari hula hari hula hula hula
hula hula Hari hula which if you were to
translate to English would be Harry hill
but the filmmakers opted not to keep the
proper Norwegian pronunciation nor to
translate the name but instead to just
anglicize it to Harry Hole great Harry
ho I don't really have a point here but
it is very funny
in the film's prologue a woman and her
son are visited by a police officer
named - Jonas the boy believes that the
abusive man is his uncle but discovers
that he is in fact his father after he
sees Jonas and his mother having sex
the woman threatens to tell Jonases wife
about their son - which Jonas threatens
to abandon them entirely and drives off
the woman and her son follow but the
woman slips into a catatonic haze drifts
off the road onto a lake and refuses to
leave the car as the ice cracks leaving
the boy to stand and watch as his mother
and the car sink into the lake the
Snowman centers around alcoholic
detective harry hole as he tries to fix
both his professional and personal lives
by focusing on work instead of drinking
he has a rocky but caring relationship
with his ex-girlfriend Raquel and her
son Oleg who is possibly also his
biological son Harry falls into the
snowman case when he meets Catrin Bratt
a junior detective just transferred into
oslo from bergen Catrin is already
pursuing the Snowman killer for personal
reasons as she suspects her father
detective Garrett Raph toe was murdered
by the killer nine years earlier while
he was investigating a string of murders
in Bergen though she keeps this
connection a secret from her coworkers
while investigating the disappearance of
Berta Becker Harry lifts the cold-case
files from katrin's bag Catrin suspects
that a recent series of missing
persons reports might be connected to
the old case and though Harry is
initially dismissive of the theory he
comes around after reading the case
files that night and the two discussed
the possible connections over breakfast
the next morning a few days later a
similar missing person is reported with
the caller asking for Harry in specific
when Harry and Catrin respond to the
call they find the missing person Sylvia
Utterson alive and well in her home
however shortly after leaving a second
call is placed and returning to the
ottarsson farm Sylvia's decapitated body
is found at the chicken coop with her
head being found propped up on a snowman
at the bottom of a large storm drain
with a confirmed murder Harry is given
clearance to set up a special task force
to clear the murders quickly in order to
avoid negative international press that
might hurt oslo's bid for the non
International Olympic Committee
trademark infringing generic Winter
Games Catrin suspects the killer is
slimeball industrialist our vase taupe
who had an affair with the original
murder victim nine years earlier or if
not him then Stopes friend dr. Adar vet
Olsen who has some connection to several
of the victims via the reproductive
services clinic that he works at Harry
discovers Katrina's personal stake in
the case when he travels to Bergen to
follow up on clues detectives failed to
investigate during the earlier case as
they had ruled Raftis death a suicide
while he is away Catrin intercepts a
notification that Berta Becker's phone
has been reactivated with a GPS
indicating that is in the home of dr.
Felson ignoring regulations and possibly
seeking revenge Catrin breaks in to
Vettel syns home where she finds his
body in the garage decapitated by a
shotgun Catrin is suspended but
investigation of Edison's home uncovers
the dismembered remains of Berta Becker
and a victim otherwise dropped from the
movie named Miss Dahl there's a Beckham
miss doll actually on my seventh viewing
of the movie I did catch one earlier
reference to miss doll from what Catrin
drops Harry off after they start
investigating Berta Becker's
disappearance no she's not the only one
but this is Haga doll missing two weeks
similar age young children unhappy
marriage on one hand it was established
earlier in the movie on the other hand
they never actually
investigate that disappearance and the
reference goes by incredibly quickly
because Rebecca Ferguson half-whispers
all of her lines egged off while the
Oslo police ruled Vettel scens death a
suicide
Harry suspects it has been staged as it
is nearly identical to the staging of
RAF tows body and also you know
incredibly suspicious
Katrine convinced that Stoke must be the
killer attempts to seduce him at a
fundraiser he gives her a key to his
hotel suite and tells her to wait for
him there she goes to the room and sets
up surveillance in the form of the most
conspicuous spy device possible but his
intercepted kidnapped and killed by the
real killer before Stoke even arrives
the following morning Harry finds
katrin's body sitting in her car outside
his apartment her finger having been
severed so the killer can use her
fingerprint to access her computer
returning to the Becker household and
talking with Berta's husband Philippe
Harry pieces together the identity of
the killer Raquel's boyfriend Matthias a
plastic surgeon who also substituted at
Vettel syns clinic and has been killing
women who have been unfaithful to their
partners and had abortions as surrogate
revenge against his mother who by his
logic abandoned him when she died at the
moment that Harry has put it all
together Matthias has kidnapped Raquel
and Oleg and takes them out to the cabin
where the film began Harry confronts
Matthias at the cabin saving Raquel and
Oleg but losing a finger in the scuffle
Harry then pursues Matthias out into the
woods onto the frozen lake
Matthias shoots Harry in the shoulder
but before he is able to finish Harry
off he steps on a patch of thin ice and
sinks into the lake in the epilogue
Harry is back at work with a new
prosthetic finger credits roll I'll take
it
[Music]
I'm not I'm not cutting that short by
the way there is zero wrap up none none
at all nothing it just the movie just
ends that's it just ends it's just
whatever just ends so I don't know if
that montage does justice to just how
consistently bonkers the editing is in
this film writing a summary is actually
a challenge because like I need the
words I'm saying to make sense but I
worry that in doing so I fixed problems
with the film by omitting details that
clash with comprehensibility like I
skipped describing the scenes with a
fumigator that Harry keeps running into
because I don't know how to describe
what these scenes are doing and he just
stopped showing up past a certain point
there's a not in substantial amount of
screen time given to a woman who I
presume is a sex trafficking victim that
vetal sin has acquired on behalf of
stope and this is I guess a red herring
to implicate either of those characters
as the possible murderer but she also
just stops showing up at a certain point
with no explanation or conclusion the
inexplicable editing of the film begins
pretty much right out the gate like the
issues here are absolutely not limited
to just characters that disappear out of
the story or motives and timelines that
don't make any sense the cutting of the
opening moments as Jonas arrives at the
cabin is extremely over tuned which is
to say that the shots being in the order
that they are in is fine but the
temporal relationship between the edits
is too abrupt just to be clear this is
on the magnitude of a number of frames
with each shot to isolate one cut in
specific that might make this easier to
understand
matías mother puts on a sweater and
moves to leave the room and in the next
shot is on the stairs down to the living
room the shot selection and screen
direction are fine but the temporal gap
between the shots is too big the first
shot ends a few frames too soon and the
second shot begins a few frames too late
making the cut feel wrong like she's
teleported and that same problem happens
with every single shot for almost two
straight minutes at the start of the
movie it makes for an intro that is
disjointed and rushed in a way that
strikes me as very odd for a film that
already has a problem with not having
enough footage like especially since
this is the opening of the film the
introduction is so important to setting
audience expectations that I don't feel
like I really need to explain why it's a
bad idea for your film to start off with
a series of cuts that are so needlessly
jarring that they look like mistakes the
one half theory that I have is that it
was originally cut to music or a title
sequence that was later dropped that
there was some other creative element
that dictated the pacing and rhythm and
is no longer present the only evidence I
have to support this though is my own
intuition and the Genki nough some of
the actual titles at the end of the
prologue matthias 'as mother sinks into
the water and then the camera tilts up
and holds on this shot for pretty much
exactly long enough that you would
expect the show title to appear it's a
nice moody static shot with lots of
white space the snowman beat be cut to
Harry's vodka bottle I mean that makes
sense to me it doesn't just look like it
was edited for the main title it looks
like it was shot for the main title
instead the film cuts from this to a
black frame where the studio credits
play one after another flat font for 22
seconds before cutting to Harry's vodka
bottle for fast Bender's credit and the
main title I'm just guessing here this
is pure speculation but this white text
on a black screen looks like a temp
placeholder that someone threw in just
to make sure it didn't get forgotten and
then no one could agree on where these
should actually go and then the
production ran out of time and money and
they just never got replaced but okay so
even if that's the reason for why the
intro is cut the way that it is
it doesn't even start to explain the
baffling creative decisions in the next
major scene when Harry returns to his
apartment and finds a fumigator spraying
for mold a scene where across a series
of jump cuts Harry
shoots at the man who doesn't seem to
notice and it remains unbothered by the
fact that a stranger is pointing a gun
at him Harry then just stands there
there is there is no intelligible
cause-and-effect here just a series of
loosely connected shots and this will be
the pace for the rest of the movie
moving on I want to talk for a bit about
ADR ADR is automated dialogue
replacement sometimes also referred to
as dubbing looping or post sync these
are processes where an actors onset
vocal performance is replaced in
post-production with audio from a studio
performance possibly by a different
actor I touched on this a bit in my
video on The Legend of chun-li the
dialogue in the film has overwhelmingly
been redubbed which is actually part of
why the performances feel so flat and
disjointed the emotion of the face and
lips just doesn't quite match the sound
that you're hearing also there's a
different character to the dialogue
that's recorded in a sound booth versus
the dialogue that's recorded on set it's
subtle but pervasive now a thing that I
want to stress here is the ADR isn't
inherently bad basically every movie has
some or even a lot of ADR ADR is a
problem-solving tool and it can be very
good at solving problems that said heavy
use of ADR is a sign that there were a
lot of problems that needed solving the
elephant in the room here is of course
Val Kilmer's performance in which all of
Kilmer's lines have been replaced
what was your wife seeing anyone now
there's a bit of a story here in 2015 as
part of a battle against throat cancer
Kilmer underwent a procedure on his
trachea that permanently altered his
voice reducing it to little more than a
rasp and leaving his tongue quite
swollen I had a tumor a couple of years
ago it's just a mystery no reason during
his performance in the Snowman it is
clearly visible difficult for him to
speak which makes the difference between
the facial performance and the sound of
the ADR so harsh
it's some information on a patient Leila
Olson
additionally attempts are made to mask
the issue by finding ways to avoid
having Val Kilmer speak on screen and
unfortunately they do this they start
this the first time in just the worst
most obvious way possible she said she
was going to visit a friend and she
never came back why did you come to me
I've been suspended now the reason I
want to specifically focus on ADR isn't
just because of Val Kilmer's dialogue
it's a big part and it is instantly
noticeable to pretty much everyone but
it's not the biggest contributor to the
deeper problems with the film the movie
is actually plagued with a lot of
moments where lines have been added over
b-roll or reaction shots in order to
construct entirely new interactions a
really obvious example for demonstrating
this is in the conversation between
Harry and the child Josephine Becker the
conversation is shot and edited
otherwise conventionally a standard shot
reverse shot with a bias towards the
character who is currently speaking
every line of dialogue is in whole or in
part on screen you've seen dialogue like
this a hundred times before it's
conventional comfortable and familiar it
adheres to the standard visual grammar
of filmmaking
this makes it all the more jarring when
at the end of the conversation we get
this last week why did you build a
snowman facing the house both sides of
this exchange the question and answer
are hidden off-screen this is an attempt
in post-production to fill the gap that
explains why Harry knows Josephine
didn't build the snowman and thus the
snowman is suspicious not that that
actually really matters because the
characters will never directly discuss
the Snowman
either way the way that plot lines have
been excised or reorganized results in
some truly disorienting stuff like the
whole sequence around Oleg's birthday
present so harry has gotten Oleg tickets
to a concert we first see them at the
beginning of the movie when Harry
stumbles back to his apartment we are
then given this sequence of events in
order Harry
attends Oleg's hockey game during which
matthias gives Harry a prescription for
sleeping pills when asked if they want
to get something to eat
Harry says he'll get something with oleg
after the show harry and oleg take the
train to the concert eating ice cream
and talking about Oleg's desire to track
down his biological father Harry and
will like have a conversation about the
father-son school trip that's coming up
and Oleg agrees to bring harry oleg asks
what the surprise is Harry says let's go
find out jump cut - the two of them
walking towards the building
Harry off-camera explains that someone
at work gave him the tickets someone at
work got me the tickets at the concert
oleg gets a text message saying urgent
message for harry the two of them leaved
the concert so harry can make a phone
call and then in a conversation
constructed entirely out of off-camera
dialogue Catrin tells Harry that a
report of another missing woman came in
asking for him by name and they need to
go now she's on her way to pick them up
aside from the utter lack of continuity
between the close up of the phone and
the
shot of the two of them in the seats and
the fact that Harry clearly says can I
borrow your phone
I need to make a call just to restate
what happens here Katrine sends Oleg a
child she doesn't know and has never met
a text message for Harry
even though Harry has a phone Catrin
drives Harry and Oleg to Raquel's home
where they drop Oleg off Harry gets back
in the car with Catrin and in another
bit of ADR
tells her to take him home they'll drive
out to the farm in the morning as the
cherry on top in the next shot there's a
minor continuity error as Harry is in
his apartment and already has the pills
that he just got the prescription for
and hasn't actually had a chance to get
yet an even simpler example of a scene
or transition being constructed of
b-roll comes a short time later Harry
and Catrin leave the farmhouse and then
over a shot of a car driving down the
highway they receive a call telling them
to go back and decide to turn around but
the car keeps driving
husband are specifically for inspector
home
[Music]
turn the car around and the timeline of
these events as presented is all over
the place the Edit suggests that it's
only been a few minutes since they left
the farm and are thus only a few minutes
away but it's pitch dark by the time
they get back hell the farm house itself
is worthy of its own consideration when
it comes to bizarre spatial editing when
the characters first arrived there's an
establishing shot of the property where
there's this large prominent cement
structure right next to the house which
is right next to the chicken coop on the
second visit again driving next to the
large cement structure after Sylvia's
twin tells them Sylvia is missing Harry
finds Sylvia's body in the chicken coop
which is again right next to the house
then there's a shot of Harry riding on
the back of a snowmobile in the middle
of a field which he jumps off and
approaches the big cement structure
which is also right next to the
farmhouse so why this whole bit with the
snowmobile where is this RAF tows entire
subplot told in flashbacks leading up to
his murder is largely just here to fill
time it doesn't actually tell us much
about the old murders that would help
unravel the new murders and RAF tow
himself is a one-note character who
doesn't really do any meaningful
investigation there's also a really good
example of how the standard language of
filmmaking can work against the film
because most of the segments showing the
audience RAF tows story are structured
visually as flashbacks but they make no
sense as flashbacks like okay what is a
flashback in the first place it's a
memory the standard structure for a
flashback is that at an appropriate
narrative moment a character has a
reason to reflect on things that happen
in the past and then those events are
shown to the audience this can be a
strong memory trigger a character
actively telling a story to others or a
character getting the information from
an external source like a journal this
is how the RAF toe sequences are built
into the film Harry browses through
katrin's documents which triggers the
flashbacks he looks at an old magazine
and transitions into a private
conversation
nine years earlier the problem is that
the language of film implies that these
are Harry's memories the magazine
contains no meaningful information on
its own
it certainly doesn't contain this
conversation and the narrative
implication is that seeing the magazine
has reminded Harry of this moment but
there's no way that these could be
Harry's memories and they're not these
are parallel sequences depicted for the
benefit of the audience but it creates a
real problem by implying things that
Harry knows but doesn't know it makes it
difficult for the audience to follow the
story because they're not sure what
Harry does and doesn't know and if the
audience is unclear on that if they
can't follow the protagonists train of
thought then the protagonists actions
start to look random and unmotivated
this is pretty much exactly what happens
in the snowman and that's not even the
film's most baffling use of cinematic
language so much of this film is shot
through dirty windows car windows tiny
windows or multiple windows that is a
visual metaphor it gets oversaturated to
the point it becomes meaningless it's
one thing to use it sparingly for
specific kinds of scenes or for specific
characters and moments to imply
something emotional about the exchange
the character's relationship with each
other or the audience's relationship to
the story but past a certain point it
stops meaning anything on its own and
just becomes an extremely noticeable
aesthetic choice there's also a
fundamental tone problem with the film I
know that comes up a lot in the movies I
talk about but it's a common problem
from what I understand Jo Nesbo's
approach to the serial killer genre
Hughes closer to black comedy not
outright farce but definitely a bit
absurdist because well serial killer
fiction is a bit absurd the idea of a
murderer who's calling card is a
sinister snowman is inherently silly but
the film plays it 100% straight
resulting in numerous moments in the
film where the soundtrack ratchets up
the tension while the camera lingers on
a frown
snowman I actually laughed out loud in
the theater when the film pulls a fake
out leading up to katrin's death she
leaves her apartment and glances at a
regular three-tier snowman with a carrot
nose before the camera swings around to
reveal to the audience that on the
backside it's actually a sad evil
snowman
it's a very very funny moment but I'm
not sure the movie agrees
so far we've mostly been pulling out
examples of janky sloppy scenes that are
hard to follow due to poor flow and
continuity but the ultimate casualty of
the deep restructuring is the core
mystery itself now the standard formula
for a mystery is to start with a bunch
of possible subjects and then narrow
them down as the characters follow leads
eliminate possibilities and build a case
the Snowman involves so many fanciful
leaps such as the killer getting in and
out of locked rooms hauling numerous
bodies long distances without notice
meticulously staged murder scenes and so
few meaningful details of psychology or
motive that leading into the climax the
only suspects that have really been
eliminated are the ones that are dead
outside of the scene in the diner the
characters don't really discuss the case
they don't talk about clues they don't
argue for or against specific suspects
they rarely talk about motives or
opportunity or logistics Harry assembles
a team to work on the case but they
don't do anything they aren't utilized
or consulted and aside from one baffling
moment where one of them tells Harry he
can't have a copy of a crime scene photo
they don't actually interact with the
case at all can I keep this
No
can I keep this
clues that are shown to the audience
like cigarette butts and footprints
aren't even collected the one scene
where the case is actually discussed in
meaningful detail the bid and the diner
is still full of so many seemingly
unmotivated responses and disconnected
shots that even after repeat viewings
it's difficult to parse what exactly the
audience is meant to learn from this
conversation and the whole is made all
the more baffling by ending on the shot
of Harry turning the plate of sausage to
reveal he's cut it apart this is a
dramatic visual but is forgive the pun
disconnected from anything that the
characters are actually talking about
the preceding line is like are you
hungry which actually makes it look like
Harry is taunting her with this action
like the dismembered sausage is supposed
to get under her skin but I don't know
because why would he do that
the note that Harry first receives is at
best an incidental detail that's
discarded long before the midpoint of
the film it's also worth mentioning that
the note used prominently in the film's
marketing mr. police I gave you all the
clues appears nowhere in the movie
though Harry does find a stack of blue
stationary in Matthias house there's a
deeper problem here in the film not
managing to follow hole events or
lettuce in on Harry's train of thought
he takes a huge detour to Bergen for
extremely unclear reasons only to
discover that Katrina's raft owes
daughter but that only sort of explains
why she's fixated on our vase nope and
does nothing to advance the actual case
on top of that Stopes viability as a
suspect is itself tenuous at best well
there's a reasonable implication that
maybe nine years ago Stoke killed his
mistress to bury an embarrassing news
story and then maybe killed the
alcoholic off-duty cop that was
investigating that disappearance there's
no reason to think that Stoke has
anything to do with the new murders or
even any of the old murders that weren't
his mistress nothing has even suggested
about how he would fit the serial killer
profile or have opportunity to kill
virtue
any of the victims to cap it off Harry
then teleports back to Oslo from Bergen
I'm not usually that much of a stickler
for movies taking some liberties with
travel time except in this case we
already devoted a significant amount of
screen time to the fact that travelling
from Oslo to Bergen is a substantial
trip like in real life the Express train
between the two cities is six and a half
hours a movie Prime's the audience's
expectations of itself and how that
manifests here is that there are so many
baffling cuts and creative decisions
that it's hard to tell which are
deliberate stylistic choices and which
are just errors random unmotivated jump
cut the movie is full of so many
inconsistencies in its basic structure
that it invert entrains the audience to
notice inconsistencies that they would
probably overlook in a better film the
reveal of Matthias as the killer feels
almost plucked out of a hat with most of
the justification being concentrated in
the reveal itself well on one hand it's
incredibly easy to identify Matthias as
the killer because he's the character
with a lot of screen time who otherwise
has nothing to do what Roger Ebert
called the law of economy of characters
and he's the only character aside from
Harry that smokes it's also difficult
because the movie is otherwise such a
mess littered with missing details and
dropped trains of thought that the
normal rules don't apply this is
actually one of the things I love about
bad movies they tend to be unpredictable
granted it tends to take the form of
being random rather than clever but hey
it's something also it's really funny
that Matthias is killing people for
getting too close when seemingly no one
actually suspects him we don't find out
what a raft Onew and there's no
indication that Vettel sin knew anything
Matthias assaults kidnaps and kills
Catrin but she was single mindedly
pursuing Stolp and doesn't even really
know he exists now maybe he killed
Catrin to frame stope but it doesn't
matter story wise because no one follows
up on anything directly connected to
Katrina's murder and the
last we see of Stoke is him sitting in
his hotel room looking sad that he
didn't get to bang the cute brunette
that was ready to jump him at the party
and that's weird that a red herring
likes taupe would just be dropped from
the story instead of being in some way
actively resolved because the movie
clearly sets up that he has implicating
evidence when he takes Katrina's photo
proving that he was one of the last
people to see her alive
compounding that the movies poor
communication of time makes it looks
like Katrina's murdered to protect
Matthias his identity and then the very
next day he kidnaps his girlfriend and
her son then calls Harry and all but
tells him he's the killer
it's not really a game of cat and mouse
but a game of a plastic surgeon
recklessly murdering a whole bunch of
people and the police who are too stupid
to catch him because they don't bother
to collect evidence he was watching us
though I'm not normally inclined to
crawl through trailers for differences
in footage it's not weird for trailers
to use elements that aren't present in
the final film and I don't think that's
wrong or deceptive but in this specific
case the trailers are a bit of a
forensic aid in assembling a picture of
exactly why certain things seem as odd
as they do the ending of the movie feels
like it was constructed entirely out of
juxtaposing disconnected shots that were
never meant to go together because it
probably was Harry gets back to the
cabin to reunite with Raquel and Oleg
and the eyelines between these two shots
just don't line up the characters don't
interact and Harry is clearly like
raising a rolling shutter or a garage
door or something and not walking into
the room also we've been given a pretty
good idea of the geography of the cabin
and it makes no sense for him to be
standing where it's implied he is like
in theory he's opening a door somewhere
on this face of the house one of the
trailers for the film feature a number
of shots of Mattias cabin as it appears
in the climax and most importantly
features shots of the cabin exploding
Herry trying to get into a burning
building clearly the original ending of
the film involved Oleg and Raquel dying
or at least appearing to die and while
we're crawling through the trailers we
might as well indulge in some forensics
of our own since we just talked about
the penultimate shot of Harry where he
is clearly opening a garage door or
something and not walking into the cabin
one of the trailers features of this
frame of harry opening a garage door to
reveal a body or possibly two sitting in
a car several other notes from the
snowman are featured there are snippets
of a conversation in the team's room at
the police station where Harry has this
seemingly quite important line building
snowmen cutting things up into little
pieces that's what a child does
testifies over there's a snowman killed
that otherwise doesn't match any
location in the final film one of the
bigger and odder things from the
trailers has to be very prominent use of
footage from a very different sequence
involving Sylvia Utterson with Sylvia
being pursued across a cement structure
through the woods and getting her foot
caught in a metal foothold trap a
sequence that I've been told is more
book accurate than Sylvia being
overpowered and killed in the chicken
coop also the color grade in the trailer
is extremely different from the final
movie now it's not weird for the grade
in a trailer to be different from the
final grade but I'm at a loss to think
of another high-profile example where
the difference was this stark the
trailer is much more saturated in higher
contrast this detail probably wouldn't
have stood out to me at all if it
weren't for the fact the grade in the
finished film is so muted that when I
watch it I feel like I'm watching
untouched footage I don't think it's
truly untouched but I'm not going to do
a shot by shot audit of dynamic range to
confirm and like here's some sample
Alexa XT raw footage from Ahri's website
the Alexa XT was the camera they used on
the film and here's the Snowman pretty
close can you blame me I mean I don't
think this is what happened I don't want
to think this is what happened I think
this is problem
léa just a creative decision that bugs
me personally but if someone on the
street walked up to me and told me that
they accidentally mastered the film
without applying the grade and then the
producers just left it because it would
cost too much to fix I wouldn't call
them a liar so that's the snowman or at
least a lot of the Snowman
it is both infuriating and fascinating
because it's actually pretty rare to see
a film in this condition typically if
something were this incomplete it just
wouldn't get released at all but instead
we get to witness the end product of the
spiral of an unfinished movie because of
what they failed to shoot the filmmakers
needed to cut more than just what was
missing taking deep bites out of
everything else in the film resulting in
a relentless parade of things that just
don't quite line up
[Music]